here are the nominees for original score
brought back mountain by Gustavo
Santaolalla
the console gardener by Albert Iglesias
Memoirs of a Geisha by John Williams
Munich by John Williams
Pride and Prejudice by Dario Morelli and
the Oscar goes to
Gustavo Santo Lajja Shanker
this is the first Academy Award
nomination for Gustavo hunter Lima he
was born in Buenos Aires Argentina
thank you so much members of the Academy
I'm so proud to have work in this movie
Brokeback Mountain movie that once again
show us that love is what makes us all
very similar in spite that we can be so
different - I want to thank a few people
I want to thank Angley for his vision he
support his guidance
I want to thank Diana asana Larry
McMurtry and Annie Proulx further
inspiration
James Shamus and David Lindley everybody
at focus kathy nelson robert messenger
but first Ari's my co-producer and
brother Anil care pill my Orchestrator
David Campbell's Bob Bernstein Ron
Goldstein I want to thank my family my
wife Alejandra my kids and I lunin Don
Juan and last but not least I want to
dedicate this to my mother
mi madre to my country Argentina and to
all the Latinos para todos Latinos
muchas gracias thank you
Jake Gyllenhaal will be here next as
well as Meryl Streep and Lily Tomlin
honoring a movie legend stay tuned to
the 78th annual Academy Awards on ABC